bro these cards are at a uh sixth grade  reading level  all right I could tell somebody wrote  These you might be at a 68 level too  [Music]  what was your first fight I was I think  15 like some backing like smokers when  there was no athletic commission to Rob  us and make us do [ __ ]  they used to have smokers you just go to  a gym a guy had a cage you'd put chairs  in and then you just [ __ ] fight  whoever showed up  where who how did it go it was actually  funny story it was with the [ __ ]  Terrace straight up I didn't learn until  after that this guy got arrested for uh  I don't know like Homeland Security [ __ ]  oh I hit him in the face I'm scared  shitless I broke his nose [ __ ] fight  ended if it was for that he'd probably  kick the [ __ ] out of me when I was 15  but he was like [ __ ] right like mid  late 20s